Speaker 1: Let's go to Alex from Orange County
next. Alex, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, how are you doing? I'm doing
well. Have you read about the senses or heard
about the latest Simpsons recently?
Speaker 1: I have now I have to ask what's
playing in the background right now?
Speaker 3: Oh, my. That's my our moms. You
want me to move or it would
Speaker 1: be yeah it will. You and I will
be able to communicate so much better if there
isn't a TV going in the background. The census.
Yes, we've covered the census. The U.S. has
three hundred and thirty one point four million
people living in it. According to the census,
it is the slowest rate of population growth
dating back a very long time. And it will
lead to two more congressional districts for
Texas. And then there are some states going
plus one, some states going minus one. So
that's the census so far.
Speaker 3: I. How's my audio, beautiful. All
right, so, yeah, I I heard all about that,
but my concern is on the streets in the district
and the congressional seats and how the GOP
might gerrymandered the way into like a House
majority.
Speaker 1: Yes. So my understanding and tell
me if this is your understanding, is that
the national census is used to determine how
many seats each state has, but it's up to
each state to draw the lines. Some states
use a sort of nonpartisan districting commission,
others its more legislature based. Is that
your understanding of how that works? Yes,
yeah, so it's a concern. It's a concern because
you take a place like Texas and I admit I've
not looked at how Texas will do this. You
look at Texas, you get two more congressional
seats. They could gerrymander the hell out
of them. I don't know if you've seen Dan Crenshaw's
district. It's gigantic. I mean, it's just
it looks like a crescent moon. It makes no
sense whatsoever. And that's why that district
is a Republican district. So that's a huge
concern.
Speaker 3: Yes, so correct me if I'm wrong,
but isn't gerrymandering illegal?
Speaker 1: Well, the thing about that is it
is against the law, it is against the law
to do it in a way where you were deliberately
disenfranchizing a protected class of people.
But the thing is proving that in court, that's
a huge process. And every once in a while,
like I think there was a decision in North
Carolina in the last few years where a judge
found that's what they did. You've got to
redraw. But that's a really expensive and
long process. And so you can you can often
still get away, even if that's what you've
done. You can still get away with it often
for one or two election cycles until until
the legal system catches up with it.
Speaker 3: OK, is there any way that even
though we have the majority, the Democrats
have the are the leaders of the House and
slightly in the Senate, is there any way that
the Democrats could prevent gerrymandering?
Speaker 1: I mean, so so Democrats in the
House and Senate and Joe Biden could put together,
in fact, H.R. one may have some gerrymandering
related provisions in it. You could pass something
like that at the at the federal level, but
then you will have lawsuits from states and
then it'll have to be adjudicated and it's
going to take some time. So can it be done
in time for twenty, twenty two? I don't know,
but it really is a state process. And so when
you have the federal government trying to
regulate a state process, you will always
have some states who say that's outside of
your purview. And so it gets the theoretical
answer is yes. The practical answer of whether
it can be done before twenty twenty two is
a question mark.
Speaker 3: OK, so with all that considering,
how do you feel about the twenty, twenty two
midterms?
Speaker 1: I'm worried I'm more worried about
the House than the Senate is how I would say
it right now. But I think it's a little too
early to say if Joe Biden continues doing
well and getting things done. I think it's
better if Joe Biden falters and Trump remains
popular and gets involved as a kingmaker.
It could look pretty ugly for Democrats in
2020 to. Delate. OK, looks like we lost him.
I appreciate the call very much, and I'm glad
to have been able to answer at least some
of your questions.